يوم امس مشاهدينا تحدثنا عن نقص مخزون
الدول الغربيه لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا ويبدو
ان هذه الدول تحاول اللجوء لمصدر جديد
للدعم صحيفه كشفت في تقرير لها انا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عرضت على عده
دول في امريكا اللاتينيه ان تتبرع
لاوكرانيا بمعداتها العسكريه القديمه
روسيا الصنع على ان تقدم لهم واشنطن اسلحه
متقدمه المقترح الامريكي قبل برفض واسع في
هذه الدول الرد الاقوى جاء من الرئيس
الكولومبي
الذي قال ان بلاده لن ترسل اسلحتها
لاوكرانيا حتى وان انتهى بها الامر كخرده
في كولومبيا الرئيس البرازيلي لولا
ديسيلفا شدد هو الاخر على انه لا مصلحه
للبرازيل في نقل الذخائر لاستخدامها في
الحرب بين اوكرانيا وروسيا وشدد على ان
العالم يحتاج الى من يريدون السلام
كلمه لم تستخدم الا قليلا حتى الان خلال
الازمه بحسب سيلفا قبل ذلك عاد المستشار
الالماني اولا
من رحلته الى البرازيل والارجنتين وتشيلي
بعد ان رفض رؤساء هذه الدول طلبا باعاده
بيع ذخير الدبابات الى بالين كما انتقد
الرئيس المكسيكي
لموافقته على ارسال دبابات لوبارد الى
اوكرانيا قائلا ان برلين تقوم بخطوات
تخالف رغبات معظم الالمان مواقف الكثير من
رؤساء امريكا اللاتينيه تتوافق مع
استطلاعات ابسوس للراي في المنطقه والتي
اظهرت ان نحو 73 بالمئه لا يؤيدون دعم
اوكرانيا وانهم يؤمنون ان بلادهم لا
تستطيع تقديم دعم مالي او عسكري لهذا
البلد
[موسيقى]